welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and the
post-credits scene for mobius has
reportedly leaked throughout this video
we're gonna be breaking down what
apparently happens after the credits
roll and how it connects to the MCU it's
also a couple of fans that claim to have
spotted the living vampire himself in
spider-man homecoming so we'll be going
over that too to discuss whether we
think it's true or not there will be
heavy spoilers here and whilst all leaks
like this should be taken with a grain
of salt it does tie in together with the
trailer so it makes a lot of sense still
it could turn out to be untrue but yeah
we don't want to potentially ruin
anything which this video will likely do
as certain elements of it seem
legitimate we're really selling this
video to you aren't we if you're still
here I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking the video now let's get
into our breakdown of the leaked of
Morbius post-credit scene okay so this
leak comes from we got this covered and
you wouldn't normally cover what they
got got us but what but it does seem to
line up a lot with the trailer and once
I get into it you'll see why people are
giving this a lot of wait the article
itself was like every blog on IMDB so
yeah it does seem to be getting picked
up by fairly reputable sources and
because of this it seems like something
we could be getting in the final film
anyway according to the website this
leak comes from the same source that
told them that Kevin Conroy would be
playing the Kingdom Come bash in a
Batman that Daniel Radcliffe was eyeing
of Moon Knight and that gal gadot would
wear golden eagle armor in Wonder Woman
1984 they often say stuff like this
before a course is some more genuine but
I did go back and specifically look at
those reports and line up the dates and
to be fair to them they did post them
way before they were officially
announced so yeah this seems more
genuine anyway according to the website
we have already seen the first post
credits scene and this centers around
Jared Leto's character Michael Morbius
coming face to face with Michael
Keaton's Adrian Toomes aka the vulture
the character who was last seen in
spider-man homecoming makes a big splash
in the trailer and the cameo was almost
like a post-credits scene for the teaser
this moment was so big that it made my
Keaton Mobius and vulture trend on
Twitter after its release and fans like
myself who were a bit so-so on the film
definitely got hooked by this scene it
pretty much made the movie a must watch
for me and though there was a spider-man
poster scene earlier in the trailer the
cameo just made the connection to the
MCU seem a lot more legitimate Sony
clearly wanted to roll this out first to
let everyone know from the off that
their movies are now connected and no
matter what Kevin Feige says they got
him they got you [ __ ] now you gotta
bring them all over hahaha after going
back and watching it reading comments
and so on it seems like quite a lot of
people online said they believed that
this would be the post-credits scene of
the film anyway and that they dropped it
in the trailer because marketing wise it
would make sense to at least show
something to get people into seats the
line that tooms says also makes a lot of
sense as to why this would be a
post-credits scene as Keaton says got
tired of doing the whole good guy thing
huh so this fits into the story with
Morbius clearly having met him before
from this it also sounds like in the
first meeting that he may have offered
Morbius something you know something
sinister something on a black couch if
you want to be in more movies you've got
to do this kind of thing Morbius anyway
from the looks of it Morbius rejected
whatever this thing was he later changed
his mind and then encountered the
character and this is why tooms asked to
be stopped being a good guy it does make
a lot of sense to me
and though it raises a lot of questions
it ties in with certain things we can
see from the trailer that at some point
Morbius does escape prison due to its
jumpsuit so it is possible that the two
characters met there and then re
encountered one another after the main
storyline of the film this clearly isn't
the first time that the two characters
have met and we may even get this and
several other cameos littered throughout
the movie there are rumors that Tom
Holland and Tom Hardy may be making
cameos but I think at best these will be
in the background of scenes
perhaps in Eddie Brock news report will
play on a TV screen in the background
and in Holland may even pop up in a
poster similar to what happened at the
end of far from home
who knows Eddie Brock may be reporting
on the Peter Parker murder story and
this would be a neat way to tie the two
together anyway back to the point at
hand
Morbius and Toombs meeting once more
lines up with what we've seen and it
does all point towards one thing
something's something dark side I mean
sinister according to the source the
second post-credit scene has tombs
introducing mobius to none other than
dr. Otto Octavius the man responsible
for the original sinister six in 1964
the context of the scene is unclear
however this does build upon the prior
line if this is true then potentially
Morbius bumped into tombs in prison and
was offered a position in the
supervillain team before turning it down
we do know that scorpion is locked up
with tooms so they could have formed a
union
Morbius likely turned it down but after
the events of the film went back to
tooms to take up the offer this turns
out to be true then I think it'll be a
massive moment in spite of US history
Sony at this point are likely trying to
set up the sinister six after they fail
to see this through due to the amazing
spider-man 2 knocking a sequel Sony
definitely wanted sinister six film and
it seems like the most logical step to
take again I do think that this report
is probably legitimate because when Yuri
watch the trailer it doesn't really seem
like the kind of thing that would pop up
in the middle of a movie and this is
definitely perfect post credit scene
material it was speculated that Jared
Harris was going to be playing the
infamous Doc Ock however he later denied
this who knows though obviously he's
going to deny because if this is a big
reveal and they will still want to keep
it a secret I am kind of in two minds
about this as I do actually think that
Harris would be a brilliant okok but
then again the actor has said he's not
doing it so yeah who knows he did
completely kill it and she Noble has a
similar sort of look to the doc and
comes across as very intelligent but
yeah if he said he's not doing it then
he probably won't be unless he wants to
be in more movies you know what you need
to do Jared I thought stop doing that
joke now I promise there's also a theory
that we may have already seen Morbius in
spider-man homecoming and eagle-eyed
fans could have potentially spotted the
character in a way that ties into the
aforementioned information before we get
into the fan theory though I just wanna
let you know we're giving away a free
copy of dr. sleep to one random
subscriber all you have to do to begin
with a chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the leaks
comment section below the winners
Calibri chosen at random on the 15th of
February in the cell be shipped out from
then to ever get surprised it's the best
of luck that everyone who takes part
okay so if you're a fan of the MCU then
you'll know that Marvel often retcon
things into their films we saw this in
the case of Peter Parker being retro
actively put into Iron Man 2 and last
year we reported on a theory that old
Steve Rogers was a Peggy Carter's
funeral which was later confirmed by the
writers of the film they often go back
and do this because it's just fun for
the fans and it makes me watching the
movies a bit more cohesive as everything
kind of ties together this fan theory
fits a similar aesthetic with many
claiming that Morbius shows up as a
prisoner during the post-credits scene
of spider-man homecoming homecoming ends
with the meeting of Adrian Toomes in
scorpion who both realized that they're
locked up together it's the start of the
world's worst bromance but there is
potentially a lot more going on here the
theory says that the bearded man that
walks behind scorpion will actually be
revealed to be Morbius and that this
will be reckoned into the film to
connect the two universes as you can see
this shot does have a bearded guy in it
however this is just a coincidence and
yeah it's definitely not Jared Leto
however as we know marble don't mind
recording things so there is potential
that it could indeed end up being in
Morbius and who knows if Sony is smart
they could show this scene from the
perspective of Morbius and this would
set up how the two characters met he has
long hair and a beard and it's probably
where most of the prison's lore'l goes
to and he also does bear some
resemblance to how the character looks
in the film so there is some leeway here
to connect the two as mentioned earlier
tooms clearly knows Morbius and with him
being locked up they likely met in
prison so this presents the perfect
opportunity for them to bump into one
another I would love it if they went
back and did this and then it's revealed
the fans that we actually got to see the
sinister six meeting all the way back in
2017 s homecoming would make for an
awesome way just to tie everything
together and I would really love it if
they managed to pull this together and
be like we were here the whole time
FeO couch because because the coat the
couch thing
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the leaks and if you think
this will happen in the film comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please give it a thumbs
up make sure you check out our breakdown
of the
first look at us aging in the upcoming
show Falcon in the Winter Soldier which
is going to be linked at the end we go
over everything you need to know about
the costume and what it means for the
universe so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
also if you want to support the channel
from as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to help making videos like this
you get access to content early and can
choose what topics we cover so please
consider donating if you want to come
chat to us after the video then either
follow us at Definition YT or click the
discord link in the description below
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with the channel and hopefully we
see over there very soon this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best now
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]